Yet with each fond remembrance, we knew, those encountered were not forgotten, that some day we would see them again.
Perhaps it was no more than wishful thinking,
but after the long calm, there are now the beginnings of a stir. The reunion at hand may bring joy,
it may bring fear, but let us embrace whatever it brings, for they are coming back. At last, the promise has been made.
Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so hopefully between screaming and crying about the game of thrones ending
you guys and seen some of the stuff coming out of E3 this is going to be like a shut up and
take my money breakdown with trailers. For those of you asking which platform I like to play on the most
typically PC is the easiest just because I have the most control over
how I capture and stream footage but I do have an Xbox One and a PS4 on the way
although because of my list here I might have to buy Wii U so let's get going. Let's start with the VR games.
so there's not a whole lot going on with VR right now so I wouldn't advise you to
like rush out and preorder one of the headsets Sony's is called project Morpheus it's really
impressive like it's supposed to be the most comfortable one and they did show off a few
games but you're locked into Sony hardware you can't use it with your PC games you can
only use it with the PS4.
(monster noises)
Welcome back, little godling.
Valve's version is called the Vive, it's a little more impressive.
It uses a couple different controllers to map your environments, so you can actually get up
and walk around inside the room where your playing games with it everybody knows about
Oculus, that's actually coming from Facebook
of all places which makes it sound a little
bit evil, its motion tracking isn't quite as impressive as Valve's Vive headset but it'll
be cheaper that's really the name of the game here. It's like what games will these support?
Will I be able to play with my PC games and my console games? Oculus that's a yes you'll be able
to play it with your PC games and with your Xbox games for sure. They announced a partnership
with Microsoft, but Microsoft is also making the Holo-Lens which is not a VR headset it's
a little bit different it's more about holograms think of it as augmented reality like you
make a hologram shoot up in the middle of your room, but your room itself isn't a VR environment
You're seeing your actual room. All the headsets right now are super glitchy
they're not going to be ready until next year so do not blow any of your money on them. I'm planning
on buying at least one of these just depending on what the support for Games is. It'll probably
end up being the Valve Vive I'm really excited to try and make make some videos with these
but the problem is, is that if you don't have the headset and you can't really take advantage
of a 3D VR video it is a very different experience, so moving into Sony they actually had
a couple surprises they had one of the better E3 presentations. Starting with Last Guardian
this is like the game that wouldn't give up I remember years ago when the PS3 first debuted
and they were like look at this beautiful game that you will never ever see and here it is
they rolled it out, so thank you very much Sony for that. They had some pretty good Star Wars Battlefront
gameplay footage I'm excited for this game Battlefront games are fun, so
even if this wasn't super great, I would still probably buy it because I'm a huge Star Wars fan. if someone
were to ask you what music makes you want to buy things the most I would say Jon Williams
Star Wars theme don't be surprised if this December like every retail store is just playing
the Star Wars theme on loop the Final Fantasy VII remake that's that's just an auto buy even
if that was terrible which it's not I would still buy it. the other auto buys should be
Kingdom Hearts 3 that was like the game everyone's been waiting for. That to me is
way more fun than Disney Infinity. Rise of the Tomb Raider also looked God damn beautiful.
Then there's the really weird Drakengard spinoff Nier 2. I think that just a temporary
name, so they might end up changing it. People are calling it hyper-violent, so I guess if you're
looking for like a more adult RPG than this to be the game for you Dragon Quest, Kingdom Hearts
those will be a lot lighter. I'm also really excited about Metal Gear Solid 5 and Uncharted
(enchanting music plays)
(birds chirp)
There's the Transformers Devastation game, which uses a lot of cell-shading
this looks like it might be fun it's a little lower on my buy list but just watching it gets me a little excited.
Moving into the world of Nintendo, so this is actually a bit of a catch 22 because they are really awful
to YouTubers, so I don't know how many Nintendo games will be playing on my YouTube channel
I will least be buying a couple of these games. The first being the new Fire Emblem game
which was like a shut up and take my money situation next to Final Fantasy, Fire Emblem is one of
my favorite franchises, I just, I've always been so disappointed it's been locked into Nintendo for so long
is also a different game, Shin Megami vs. Fire Emblem which looks even more ridiculous
in the best possible way, seriously this is like an anime hot mess if you're a big anime fan this
is good be your game. Really the interesting one was Star Fox Zero. I haven't played a Star Fox
game in a long time so this might be the one to gets me back in. It just had some really
interesting gameplay mechanics so so we'll see. I mean I even like the N64 version that
was the last version that I played that's how long it's been.
(epic music plays)
Moving into Ubisoft, so there are actually a couple pretty good games. South Park: The Fractured but Whole, I really loved what they did was
Stick of Truth. South Park, itself just the way the animate the TV show is perfect for
video games it's already kind of a video game.
Alright, who put the Stick of Truth in the toilet? That is not funny, this is a holy relic.
Moving into Bioware territory starting with Mass Effect Andromeda, they said that this won't involve Commander Shepherd
from the main series and will be in a completely different place which I'm totally fine with so moving into Microsoft
territory course Halo 5 auto buy, no need for an explanation there, same for Fallout 4
the really impressive thing about that
is that they dropped the mobile game immediately.
That's like the most perfect presentation ever where it's like, look at this acid trip of
the game is going to melt your brain, oh wait, we have a mobile game that you can download, right now.
Bethesda has Doom, that was one of
those games that made my dad buy me my own
computer because I hogged our family computer so much playing it. Right off the bat I know
a lot of you are asking which of these I'm and to be streaming on my game channel. For those of you who don't know,
yes, I do have like a bonus game channel which is called Charlie Streams. There's a link in the description.
I'll say definitely Fallout 4, Halo 5, and then the Square games like Final Fantasy, Nier 2, just depending on what Square Enix
allows to be streamed. Most of the big game publishers are really nice about gameplay videos,
but some of the games are just off-limits
like Nintendo is a really good example of that
so that's why I'm probably not going to be doing a lot of Nintendo videos. What I'm hoping is, is that
by the time most of these games come out later this year I will have someone helping me so
I'll have more time to do games so I'll at least do like one game video per day on my game channel
YouTube has this new videogame website that nobody really understands that well so once
I figure out what's going on with that I'll post an update just in general though expect
more gameplay videos later this year Arkham Knight is coming up so I'll probably do a little bit
of that right away but this is mostly just intended to be like a shout out for the games that I
got really excited for it E3 but if there
are any games that you guys really wanted
to play just let me know in the comments like let me know what are the games that you saw at E3
that your most excited about. I don't have an ETA right now on gameplay videos so just
follow me on Twitter and Facebook for updates there are links that in the description and
a link to my bonus channel but while you guys wait for all that stuff you can click here
for my Game of Thrones Finale Q&A just to to learn about what's going on with Season Six,
and you can click here for my Season Six Predictions if you haven't seen them yet.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody let's everybody High Five, now Shut Up and Take My Money
(ending music plays)